is just before we let you go I have to
ask about tomorrow's winers final
against Dennis lazic how are you feeling
about that one how depressed are you so
far with his run am I not playing
tomorrow I that was my bad
tricky perhaps with uh some changes you
know some new people to work with better
influences maybe he can um he can play
even better Magnus uh you're were saying
better influences like are you talking
about Hans nean right
now uh I'm talking about influences in
in general Fabby needs to win the
tournament to to get to
London well I think the last few months
I've generally won tournaments in which
Magnus is playing in
so I I I meant I didn't mean to to trash
talk I meant to just State something
factual